- [Narrator] Why does your vote matter?
- Your vote matters because,
in the most specific case,
there might be a race where you live,
for the House or the Senate
or even the presidency,
where your vote really could
determine who the winner
of that race is.
We saw in the 2000
presidential election race,
that basically the entire
presidency was determined
by a difference of 537 votes in Florida.
So that's a special case,
but then also, there are reasons to vote
that have nothing to do with
the people who are running
for the national offices.
There are lots of local
offices where laws are
put on the book that really can
affect your day-to-day life.
There's also referendums in
various states and localities.
There are about 150-odd
referendas on everything
from whether marijuana should be legalized
to whether and how poor
people get medical coverage.
Those are also on the
ballet in a lot of places.
And also, when a vote
takes place for somebody
who is being elected, it's
not just for the policies
of the day, it's also for the
policies that may yet come.
And if you have a view on the
way things should be handled,
you should exercise your voice
because it not only, if you are in a place
where your vote is not
gonna matter in terms
of directly electing the person you want,
voting sends a message to those lawmakers.
And it sends one of two kinds of messages.
One, it says this number of people
represents this viewpoint.
And lawmakers should listen
to that kind of message
from the voters.
A lot of times, even if
they don't listen to it,
well their opponents will
be able to raise it and say,
Look, this many people believe
in this and you should.
It is a fact that is then
used in public debate.
And that fact can sometimes
be used to persuade people.
Also, there's the case
that lawmakers get nervous.
And they want to get re-elected.
And if they see a lot
of people turning out
on the other side, even
if it doesn't keep them
from being elected, well, the next time,
it might keep them from being elected.
So they have to listen.
Finally, it's the spiritual,
kind of American civic religion,
which is America started
on the idea that we could govern ourselves
without resorting to fights.
And we've been remarkably successful.
Although American history is blotted,
and it is broken in places,
but Americans have always
transferred power
peacefully to each other,
with the one great
exception of the Civil War.
But the electoral system still survived,
even through that most bloody battle.
And so as Americans, by voting,
we are putting ourselves
back in touch with this
great original experiment,
that at its time was
unique in American history.
And there are still people
all across the world
who fight and die for the
simple ability to cast a vote
so that their voice can be heard.
And so not only to we have to keep faith
with our own history,
but also with the world
in which it is a human right
in some places to vote.
And so we shouldn't take that
kind of thing for granted,
if we want a world in which
human beings are allowed
to voice their vote and have
that vote mean something
in the way the laws are made
that determine how their lives are lived.